This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. People all over the world are flirting with an idea called basic income. Basic income. Basic income. Basic income for all. The idea behind the basic income is that each citizen receives a payment every month as a right without conditions and paid individually. Basic income. Also known as universal basic income or unconditional basic income or UBI. That's producer Avery Trouffleman. Very very roughly defined, universal basic income is this idea that a government would
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。世界各地的人们都在尝试一种叫做“基本收入”的理念。基本收入。基本收入。全民基本收入。基本收入背后的理念是，每个公民每月都能无条件地、以个人名义获得一笔作为权利的款项。基本收入。也被称为全民基本收入、无条件基本收入或UBI。那是制作人艾弗里·特鲁夫曼。非常粗略地定义，全民基本收入就是政府会
pay all their citizens. And everyone would get a flat sum of money every month to cover their basic needs, whether or not they have a job. And this money would be no strings attached with no conditions, and this would hopefully remove any stigma from receiving it. It's free money, basically, it's free money. The logic behind it is this.
支付给所有公民。每个人每月都会得到一笔固定金额的钱来满足基本需求，无论他们是否有工作。这笔钱将没有任何附加条件，希望这能消除领取它的任何污名。基本上，这就是免费的钱，是免费的钱。其背后的逻辑是这样的。
A lot of jobs don't pay enough money for people to even make rent or buy groceries. You can work full-time and still be below the poverty line, so it's easy to understand why people on the left would advocate for a guaranteed income. But also, a version of this concept is popular in libertarian circles. They see basic income as a way to shrink the welfare state. For example, you could take away food stamps, Medicare, and housing subsidies, and replace all of it with one flat sum. People in tech are also interested in the concept of basic income, and they feel a certain
很多工作提供的薪水甚至不足以让人支付房租或购买食品杂货。你可以全职工作，但收入仍低于贫困线，所以很容易理解为什么左翼人士会主张保障收入。但这种概念的一个版本在自由意志主义圈子里也很受欢迎。他们将基本收入视为缩小福利国家规模的一种方式。例如，你可以取消食品券、医疗保险和住房补贴，并用一笔固定金额取而代之。科技界的人士也对基本收入的概念很感兴趣，他们感到一种
urgency about it. Robots are coming for our jobs, they say. And basic income is the best way for humans to maintain a decent lifestyle when our labor is increasingly obsolete. Our generation is going to have to deal with tens of millions of jobs replaced by automation like self-driving cars and trucks. But we have the potential to do so much more than that. That's Mark Zuckerberg, giving a commencement speech
紧迫感。他们说，机器人正在抢走我们的工作。而当我们的劳动力日益过时，基本收入是人类维持体面生活方式的最佳途径。我们这一代人将不得不面对数以千万计的工作岗位被自动驾驶汽车和卡车等自动化技术所取代。但我们有潜力做得更多。那是马克·扎克伯格在哈佛大学毕业典礼上的演讲。
at Harvard. And what he's getting at is, in a world where jobs are scarce, everyone will need a financial cushion. And then, by his logic, if people don't have to worry about food and shelter, maybe they'd feel freer to innovate. Maybe they'd start a new company or go back to school. We should explore ideas like universal basic income to make sure that everyone has a cushion
在哈佛大学。他想表达的是，在一个工作稀缺的世界里，每个人都需要一个经济缓冲。按照他的逻辑，如果人们不必担心食物和住所，也许他们会感到更自由去创新。也许他们会创办一家新公司或重返校园。我们应该探索像全民基本收入这样的想法，以确保每个人都有一个缓冲
to try new ideas. Listen to that Harvard crowd, they're just eating it up. Elon Musk has also advocated for UBI, and the startup incubator Y Combinator will soon begin its own pilot experiment right here in Oakland to study what happens when they give a group of people a basic income. It's actually an idea that's been around for a long time, and there are many different variations on it. But recently, there have been a number of experiments with forms of basic income happening around
来尝试新的想法。听听哈佛那群人的反应，他们非常受用。埃隆·马斯克也主张实行UBI，创业孵化器Y Combinator很快将在奥克兰开始自己的试点实验，研究当他们给一群人提供基本收入时会发生什么。这实际上是一个存在已久的想法，并且有许多不同的变体。但最近，世界各地出现了许多关于基本收入形式的实验。
the world. A nonprofit is running an experiment with UBI in Kenya and Ontario, Canada just launched a test in three different cities. But this recent excitement about basic income experimentation is largely focused on Finland. Finland will be the first country in the world to find it a basic income. Finland's experiment with universal basic income. Is it a great idea?
一家非营利组织正在肯尼亚进行UBI实验，加拿大安大略省刚刚在三个不同的城市启动了一项测试。但最近这种对基本收入实验的兴奋主要集中在芬兰。芬兰将成为世界上第一个尝试基本收入的国家。芬兰的全民基本收入实验。这是一个好主意吗？
Is it just Finnish, financial, folly? In the beginning of 2017, the Finnish government began an experiment with a basic income. Is it a great idea? Was it just finished financial? Follow. In the beginning of 2017, the Finnish government began an experiment with a basic income. And this news about the Finland experiment was really exciting. Maybe we will learn what people will do if they can make money without work. Will they just hang out at home? Will society grind to a halt?
这只是芬兰的财政愚行吗？2017年初，芬兰政府开始了一项基本收入实验。这是一个好主意吗？这只是芬兰的财政愚行吗？2017年初，芬兰政府开始了一项基本收入实验。关于芬兰实验的消息确实令人兴奋。也许我们会了解到，如果人们不工作也能赚钱，他们会做什么。他们会整天待在家里吗？社会会陷入停滞吗？
How will people find meaning in their lives and how will they evaluate success? And that's of course the big question. It's the kind of the acid test of basic income that we're receiving basic income make people more or less active. Whatever the activity is, whether it's just walking around
人们将如何在生活中寻找意义，他们将如何评估成功？这当然是最大的问题。这是基本收入的试金石，即我们获得基本收入会使人们变得更活跃还是更不活跃。无论活动是什么，无论是只是四处走走
or whether it's taking care of your neighborhood's kids or applying for work. This is Rope Muka. Founder of DemoSeltsinke, we are a Helsinki-based team, thank. And here's what I learned talking to Rope and other people in Finland about this experiment with basic income. To talk about basic income in Finland started before the understanding of what the outcomes of automation would be for the employment market.
还是照顾邻居的孩子，或者是申请工作。这是罗普·莫卡。Demo Helsinki的创始人，我们是一个位于赫尔辛基的团队，谢谢。这就是我与罗普以及芬兰其他人谈论这个基本收入实验时学到的东西。在芬兰谈论基本收入始于了解自动化对就业市场的影响之前。
The Finland experiment is not about robots, and it's not to see if people will stop working when they get free money. The experiment is to find out if giving people basic income will actually help them start working. And this whole experiment is especially interesting to us here at 99PI, not just for what Finland is testing, but how they are testing it. Finland is trying out a unique design-oriented way of thinking about government.
芬兰的实验与机器人无关，也不是为了观察人们在获得免费资金后是否会停止工作。该实验旨在找出向人们提供基本收入是否真的能帮助他们开始工作。整个实验对我们99PI来说特别有趣，不仅是因为芬兰在测试什么，还因为他们测试的方式。芬兰正在尝试一种独特的、以设计为导向的政府思维方式。
Rather than just rolling out laws on a massive scale, they are trying to craft legislation in stages with user feedback, like a piece of design. Because every good design is made to fill a need or solve a problem. And this is the problem. I hate it to be unemployed. Right now in 2017, the unemployment rate in Finland is at 8.8%. And that's about double the US unemployment rate. And that rate is worse than smaller finished cities like Yo-N-Soo.
他们不是在大规模地推行法律，而是试图分阶段制定立法，并根据用户反馈进行调整，就像一件设计作品。因为每一个好的设计都是为了满足需求或解决问题而制作的。这就是问题所在。我讨厌失业。目前在2017年，芬兰的失业率为8.8%。这大约是美国失业率的两倍。而且这个比率比像约恩苏这样的小型芬兰城市还要糟糕。
Yo-N-Soo is in Eastern Finland. Eastern Finland has always been poorest parts of the country. This is Sana Leskenin, resident of Yon Su, which is about an hour's drive away from the Russian border. She's 39 and she's been unemployed for a little over two years. Unemployment has been here bigger than say in southern or western Finland because we are far from bigger cities where are much, much, much, much more job opportunities.
约恩苏位于芬兰东部。芬兰东部一直是该国最贫穷的地区。这是萨娜·莱斯基宁，约恩苏的居民，距离俄罗斯边境大约一小时车程。她39岁，已经失业两年多了。这里的失业率比芬兰南部或西部要高，因为我们远离大城市，那里有更多、更多、更多、更多的工作机会。
Sana has a master's in history and she worked as a researcher until her project ran out of funding. And all over Finland, there's been a massive decline in manufacturing work. Ever since Nokia was crushed by Apple and Android phones, Nokia's phone parts used to be made by contractors and companies all around the country.
萨娜拥有历史硕士学位，在项目资金耗尽之前，她一直担任研究员。在整个芬兰，制造业工作出现了大规模的衰退。自从诺基亚被苹果和安卓手机击垮后，诺基亚的手机零部件过去是由全国各地的承包商和公司制造的。
My mom actually worked in that factory that kind of went down when Nokia sat at Go Down, so I kind of know part of that story pretty well. In the US, depending on the state, you can generally collect unemployment for about half a year after losing a job. In Finland, you can generally collect unemployment for about half a year after losing a job. In Finland, you can collect unemployment for about two years. And then there are different kinds of social assistance and allowances you can apply for.
我妈妈实际上就在那家工厂工作，当诺基亚倒闭时，那家工厂也随之倒闭了，所以我对那个故事的一部分了解得相当清楚。在美国，根据所在州的不同，失业后通常可以领取大约半年的失业救济金。在芬兰，失业后通常可以领取大约半年的失业救济金。在芬兰，你可以领取大约两年的失业救济金。然后还有你可以申请的其他各种社会援助和津贴。
If you still don't have a job. But here's the catch. If you're collecting unemployment assistance in Finland, you generally cannot earn additional income or you risk losing those benefits. And then you'd have to reapply, which is a massive drag. You cannot take like part-time job because then you are gaining money even though very, very little. Then it's counted against you. And so you lose that little bit of support money you were already gaining. So unemployed fins don't want to risk that loss. They don't want to pick up temporary
如果你仍然没有工作。但问题来了。如果你在芬兰领取失业救济金，你通常不能赚取额外收入，否则你可能会失去这些福利。然后你必须重新申请，这非常麻烦。你不能做兼职工作，因为那样你就会赚钱，尽管非常非常少。然后这会被计入你的收入，所以你会失去你已经获得的那一点点支持资金。因此，失业的芬兰人不想冒这个险。他们不想从事临时
gig work or part-time jobs or freelance work. So it's really, really difficult situation. This actually happened with the person we hired to record Sana. We asked what his rate was, and he said he couldn't charge us because he is also an employed and would lose part of his allowance if he took on money from freelance work. So he did it for free. Thanks, Yana. Basically, the government of Finland realized that something had to be done about this system, that they were accidentally disincentivizing citizens from getting small jobs, or maybe even starting businesses of their own.
零工、兼职工作或自由职业。所以这确实是一个非常非常困难的情况。这实际上发生在我们雇来录制萨娜的那个人身上。我们问他的费率是多少，他说他不能向我们收费，因为他也是失业者，如果他接受自由职业的钱，就会失去部分津贴。所以他是免费做的。谢谢，亚娜。基本上，芬兰政府意识到必须对这个系统做些什么，他们无意中阻止了公民去寻找小工作，甚至可能阻止了他们自己创业。
And these are citizens who want to work like Santa. Being unemployed makes me feel anyway sort of, I don't know, unimportant. I mean, doing a job would make you feel like you're doing something for, you know, a purpose in something. But being unemployed, you're just hanging around and just not being very important to anything, anybody. So this welfare system clearly needs to be changed, and this could be done in a few different ways, like with an earned income tax credit, but first they wanted to try out something simpler and go from there. And this is where we get to design. They wanted to design and test policy in a process very similar to the way designers come up with new products.
而这些公民是像萨娜一样想要工作的人。失业让我觉得，无论如何，我不重要。我的意思是，做一份工作会让你觉得你在为某个目的做些什么。但失业了，你只是闲逛，对任何事情、任何人都不重要。所以这个福利制度显然需要改变，这可以通过几种不同的方式来完成，比如通过劳动所得税抵免，但首先他们想尝试一些更简单的方法，然后从那里开始。这就是我们谈到设计的地方。他们想以一种与设计师构思新产品非常相似的过程来设计和测试政策。
You would design policies that you would think about policies as kind of design objects or design services. And that means that you could do iteration and tests. That's Robyn Mokka again, founder of Think Tank demo's Helsinki, and the Prime Minister's office turned to them. So the Prime Minister's office approached us and asked us how can we employ design thinking on a national level? How can we do like governmental level design thinking?
你会设计政策，你会把政策看作是一种设计对象或设计服务。这意味着你可以进行迭代和测试。那是罗宾·莫卡，智库Demo Helsinki的创始人，总理办公室求助于他们。所以总理办公室联系了我们，问我们如何在国家层面运用设计思维？我们如何进行政府层面的设计思维？
Design thinking. It goes like this. First, there is a challenge or problem that must be solved. Then designers express, test, and cycle. Express. That means designers come up with a few ideas in prototypes. Test. They try those ideas out, maybe with a model or a sample.
设计思维。它是这样的。首先，有一个必须解决的挑战或问题。然后设计师表达、测试和循环。表达。这意味着设计师提出一些想法和原型。测试。他们尝试这些想法，也许用模型或样本。
Get feedback and understand what actually happens, what are the outcomes. And, cycle. Incorporate that feedback to make changes and revise the design. Then the process begins again, and again, and again, in different iterations. Couple years ago, this is how the Finnish prime minister decided he wanted to design legislation. Also, the prime minister, I mean,
获取反馈并了解实际发生了什么，结果是什么。然后，循环。结合这些反馈进行更改并修改设计。然后这个过程又开始了，一次又一次，在不同的迭代中。几年前，这就是芬兰总理决定他想要设计立法的方式。而且，总理，我的意思是，
he's not a radical necessarily, right? He's like a centrist. Yeah, absolutely. I think this is the most interesting part of the story that there was a true frustration among policymakers that they don't know what a particular law or tax would cause, whether it actually would work. So demos helped establish an experimentation unit, which is an actual office of the Finnish Prime Minister. The Prime Minister's office is experimentation unit. It's the first unit that was like designs policy is in the kind of design thinking meaning of the word. There are other governments that are interested in experimentation,
他并不一定是个激进分子，对吧？他就像个中间派。是的，绝对。我认为这是故事中最有趣的部分，政策制定者中存在一种真正的挫败感，他们不知道某项法律或税收会导致什么，也不知道它是否真的有效。因此，Demos帮助建立了一个实验部门，这是芬兰总理的一个实际办公室。总理办公室的实验部门。这是第一个以设计思维的含义来设计政策的部门。还有其他政府对实验感兴趣，
but here's what makes Finland different. They want to create prototypes of laws and then change and scale and update them dynamically as the results of their experiments show what's effective and what's not. And in order to run these experiments Finland actually had to pass a law to ensure that they were not in violation of their constitution. Because all the constitutions of democratic countries in the world they say that you have to treat people equally. And by definition if you're running experiments you're not treating people equally. Because they, the people who are part of the experiments, are not being treated equally. So they need to be a special law that outlined that, okay, how do the experiments fit in the constitution that says that people need to be treated equally?
但这就是芬兰的不同之处。他们想要创建法律的原型，然后随着实验结果显示什么是有效的，什么是无效的，动态地改变、扩展和更新它们。为了进行这些实验，芬兰实际上不得不通过一项法律，以确保他们没有违反宪法。因为世界上所有民主国家的宪法都说你必须平等对待人们。根据定义，如果你在进行实验，你就没有平等对待人们。因为他们，那些参与实验的人，没有受到平等待遇。所以需要有一项特别法律来概述，好吧，实验如何符合宪法中关于人们需要受到平等待遇的规定？
And one of the first experiments, the Finnish government decided to do, was with basic income. Because the welfare office is extensive and complicated and rather than rejiggering one part of it and changing a bunch of stuff around and reworking their normal operations, the basic income experiment just kind of chugs along that zone. We have automated and partly automated our processes so everything is run by computers. The money, the basic income, just gets deposited in participants bank accounts every month automatically.
芬兰政府决定进行的首批实验之一是关于基本收入的。因为福利办公室规模庞大且复杂，与其重新调整其中的一部分，改变一堆东西，并重做他们的正常运作，基本收入实验只是顺其自然地进行。我们已经自动化并部分自动化了我们的流程，所以一切都由计算机运行。这笔钱，基本收入，每个月都会自动存入参与者的银行账户。
The program is currently overseen by Marjuka Turunen, who works for a government institution called Kella. Kella, so that's a social insurance institution here in Finland, so I was in charge of implementing this basic income experiment or head of it, project leader. There's not a lot of stigma about welfare in Finland. Everyone goes to this office every now and then in life, because there are 40 different kinds of benefits that Thins can receive,
该项目目前由玛朱卡·图鲁宁监督，她在芬兰一个名为Kela的政府机构工作。Kela，那是芬兰的一个社会保险机构，所以我负责实施这个基本收入实验，或者说是它的负责人，项目负责人。在芬兰，关于福利的污名并不多。每个人一生中都会时不时地去这个办公室，因为芬兰人可以获得40种不同的福利，
including student support, paternal care, maternal care, pension subsidies, and of course, unemployment. So in January of 2017, Kela picked 2,000 unemployed fans at random from all over the country. In this experiment we have 2,000 people who are getting this basic income, 560 euros per month. And so they have to be between 25 to 58, so they are not students or young people, and they are not those kind of people who will feel out their pension age during this experiment. So this is kind of like the profile of these people.
包括学生支持、父亲护理、母亲护理、养老金补贴，当然还有失业救济。所以在2017年1月，Kela从全国各地随机挑选了2000名失业的芬兰人。在这个实验中，我们有2000人获得了这个基本收入，每月560欧元。他们必须在25到58岁之间，所以他们不是学生或年轻人，也不是那些在这个实验期间会达到退休年龄的人。所以这就是这些人的概况。
Participants didn't volunteer for the experiment. Kelli just told them that they would now be receiving 560 euros a month. The news came in a letter. I got a fat, fat male and this said that, okay, you happy Joe said to be one in this basic income experiment and I was like, oh, what's that? Sana, the unemployed researcher in Yohansu, hadn't really thought about basic income until she read that big fat packet that came in the mail, which outlined the experiment for her. And I was going to have the certain amount of money to my bank
参与者并没有自愿参加实验。Kela只是告诉他们，他们现在每月将收到560欧元。消息是在一封信中传达的。我收到了一封厚厚的邮件，上面说，好吧，你很幸运被选中参加这个基本收入实验，我当时想，哦，那是什么？萨娜，约恩苏的失业研究员，在读到那封寄来的厚厚信件之前，并没有真正考虑过基本收入，信件为她概述了实验内容。我每个月都会有一定数额的钱存入我的银行
account every month. It's not big, but it's stable money. Five hundred six years a month would be a little less than SANA would get on unemployment, but you'd also be able to work and not worry about losing it. So I was happy about it because two years that experiment lasts, it's gonna be that money every month. And I don't have to stress that much because I am a big stressor person. I stress a lot. And finding a job was very important to me. So now I'm able, if I find a job, in like a part time job, I could take it and not lose the support money that usually would, if I wasn't part of this basic income experiment.
账户。虽然不多，但很稳定。每月560欧元会比萨娜在失业救济金中获得的少一点，但她也可以工作，而不必担心失去它。所以我对此感到高兴，因为实验持续两年，每个月都会有那笔钱。我不必那么紧张，因为我是一个非常容易紧张的人。我压力很大。找工作对我来说非常重要。所以现在，如果我找到一份工作，比如兼职工作，我可以接受它，而不会失去如果我不参加这个基本收入实验通常会失去的支持资金。
Some of the participants have been talking about their basic income with the press, but Sana has kept it a secret. I feel embarrassed about it because it feels like I have this advantage. So I haven't been very excited about spreading that information and now as I'm participating this, your podcast is like, okay, not many, many people in Finland are probably hearing about this, so I could be open to put it. I'm sorry to put it this way.
一些参与者一直在与媒体谈论他们的基本收入，但萨娜一直保密。我对此感到尴尬，因为感觉我拥有这种优势。所以我对传播这些信息并不感到兴奋，现在因为我正在参与这个，你们的播客就像是，好吧，芬兰可能没有多少人听说过这个，所以我可以公开。我很抱歉这样说。
I'll have you know, we are huge in Finland, Sauna. Sauna doesn't know anyone else involved in the study, and most people in Finland don't. Her friends get kind of star-struck when she tells them her secret. I get people, you know, of God with that. So, oh, you're part of that. You're the first one I've ever met. So, it's like, he's kind of funny, really.
我要让你知道，萨娜，我们在芬兰非常受欢迎。萨娜不认识研究中的其他人，芬兰的大多数人也不认识。当她告诉朋友她的秘密时，他们会有点被明星光环震住。我让人，你知道，天哪，是吗。哦，你是其中的一员。你是我见过的第一个。所以，这有点好笑，真的。
When you collect unemployment in Finland, you have to go to these job training meetings and check-ins every couple of months. But these 2000 participants scattered around the country don't have to do anything at all to get this 560 euros every month. Even though they're part of this experiment, they also don't have to report how they spent it. And at the end of the experiment, Kelo will look and see if this group of unemployed people who got basic income took on work
在芬兰领取失业救济金时，你必须每隔几个月参加这些工作培训会议和签到。但这些分散在全国各地的2000名参与者每个月什么都不用做就能得到这560欧元。尽管他们是这个实验的一部分，但他们也不必报告他们是如何花掉这笔钱的。在实验结束时，Kela会查看并观察这群获得基本收入的失业者是否开始工作
and compare it with their control group, which is the rest of the unemployed people of Finland. 175,000 people who are in the same profile than these 2,000 people are, but they are not getting this basic income. So we are comparing these two groups of people in this two years period and see what is happening to these. How are these people behaving when they get this basic income and how are these people behaving not getting the basic income? And then when they compare the results, basic income might just might get one step closer to becoming a reality. Well, if you play with the idea that this basic income would actually come a universal basic income here in Finland, which is kind of like the idea that I don't actually believe
并将其与对照组进行比较，对照组是芬兰其余的失业者。有175,000人与这2000人的情况相同，但他们没有获得基本收入。所以我们正在比较这两组人在两年期间的情况，看看发生了什么。当人们获得基本收入时，这些人表现如何，而没有获得基本收入的人表现又如何？然后当他们比较结果时，基本收入可能，只是可能，离成为现实更近了一步。好吧，如果你玩弄这个想法，即这个基本收入实际上会成为芬兰的全民基本收入，这有点像我不相信
that he's going to happen. Yeah, thank you. Well, I think that there are lots of people who are not thinking this is a good idea. Yes, the person currently overseeing the experiment for basic income believes it won't work. I think that it would be true dramatic. So we would wipe out all of this social security system that we have been building up for decades and then just replace it with one benefit. Toto and I imagines that not everyone would prefer a flat income rate. Some people do need more
它会发生。是的，谢谢。好吧，我认为有很多人不认为这是一个好主意。是的，目前监督基本收入实验的人认为它不会奏效。我认为这太戏剧化了。我们将抹去我们几十年来建立的所有社会保障体系，然后用一项福利取而代之。托托和我认为并不是每个人都更喜欢统一的收入标准。有些人确实需要超过
than one based sum. Like, what if you have children or parents with special needs who you have to take care of all day? In that case, you don't have the capacity to start picking up gig work. The basic income wouldn't be enough for you. And of course, who would pay for it, so who would finance it? It's really hard to say how much basic income would actually cost the average taxpayer, were it to be instituted. And we don't quite know how it would affect the economy or inflation rates. It's all dependent on a number of factors and there's no exact math on this. If someone truly claims that they know how much more
一个基本总额。比如，如果你有孩子或有特殊需求的父母需要你整天照顾怎么办？在这种情况下，你没有能力开始从事零工。基本收入对你来说是不够的。当然，谁来支付它，谁来资助它？很难说如果实施基本收入，普通纳税人实际上会花费多少钱。我们也不太清楚它会如何影响经济或通货膨胀率。这一切都取决于许多因素，对此没有精确的数学计算。如果有人真的声称他们知道基本收入会贵多少
expensive basic income would be, I think they're lying. It's such a systemic shift that if we decide to start paying everyone a lump sum of money it will change the economy in such way that the whole system changes. It's like once again something we have to experiment. Rope says that, yes, basic income would save money by cutting back on bureaucracy, but it would probably still be expensive to fund. But that's almost technical.
我认为他们在撒谎。这是一个如此系统性的转变，如果我们决定开始向每个人支付一笔总额的钱，它将以这样一种方式改变经济，以至于整个系统都会改变。这就像再一次我们需要实验的东西。罗普说，是的，基本收入会通过减少官僚主义来节省资金，但资助它可能仍然很昂贵。但这几乎是技术性的。
If you need money, you raise money. It's like what politicians do. They change the way budgets are arranged. If basic income makes citizens become more active and engaged, Gropa has faith that governments will find a way to pay for it. Because an excited and activated population is generally good for the economy,
如果你需要钱，你就筹集资金。这就像政客们做的那样。他们改变预算安排的方式。如果基本收入使公民变得更加活跃和参与，罗普相信政府会找到支付它的方法。因为一个兴奋和活跃的人口通常对经济有好处，
he says that's why they have to test before anything else if basic income would really increase productivity and improve general well-being. At this point, they're testing to see if it'd be worth more investigation. I really, really, really hope that this will continue and to spread out that more people are involved. This experiment has invigorated sauna.
他说这就是为什么他们必须在任何其他事情之前测试基本收入是否真的会提高生产力并改善整体福祉。在这一点上，他们正在测试看看它是否值得更多的调查。我真的，真的，真的希望这能继续下去并传播开来，让更多的人参与进来。这个实验让萨娜焕发了活力。
Even though she gets slightly less money than she would on unemployment, she is free to do whatever she wants. I am trying to find a job. I am sending a blog application and take possibly a part-time job. She feels like she's about to start a new chapter, and she's ready for what's next. A tranquility of a mind, it brought that to me. And it sounds funny because the amount of money is not that big. But
尽管她得到的钱比失业救济金稍微少一点，但她可以自由地做任何她想做的事。我正在努力找工作。我正在发送博客申请，并可能从事兼职工作。她觉得她即将开启新篇章，她为接下来的一切做好了准备。内心的宁静，它带给了我。这听起来很有趣，因为钱的数额并不大。但是
give people hope, give people a chance to take a moment away from their stress and that panic of do we survive. It's really important to keep in mind that Son is just one participant in a very small study. And basic income may have helped her search for part-time work, but when I spoke with her, she had yet to actually find employment. And also, you probably noted that this form of basic income is not universal basic income. If it were universal, it would be money
给人们希望，给人们一个机会，让他们从压力和那种“我们能生存吗”的恐慌中解脱出来。记住萨娜只是一个小规模研究中的一名参与者非常重要。基本收入可能帮助她寻找兼职工作，但当我与她交谈时，她还没有真正找到工作。而且，你可能注意到这种形式的基本收入不是全民基本收入。如果是全民的，那将是钱
for every citizen employed or not. In this particular experiment, the basic income is only for unemployed people. Yeah, I think what we're experimenting now would be called partial basic income. This is a limited experiment. I don't know how relevant it is because a lot of groups are missing. If we want to see what people do when they don't have to work anymore, Ropeus says they should next see what happens if basic income is given to people who are already employed
给每个公民，无论是否就业。在这个特定的实验中，基本收入仅针对失业者。是的，我认为我们现在正在实验的应该被称为部分基本收入。这是一个有限的实验。我不知道它有多大的相关性，因为很多群体都缺失了。如果我们想看看当人们不再需要工作时会做什么，罗普说他们接下来应该看看如果基本收入提供给已经就业的人会发生什么
to see if they then quit their jobs. Critics of the experiment also argue that 2,000 people is too small a sample size. Two Finnish economists published an op-ed in the New York Times called, Why Finland's Basic Income Experiment Isn't Working, and said it had the potential to incentivize people to accept low-p pain and low productivity jobs. It's an experiment that's far from perfect, but it's not supposed to be a be-all-end-all. Ideally, it's a first draft. We cannot just consider that, you know,
看看他们是否会辞职。实验的批评者还认为2000人的样本量太小。两位芬兰经济学家在《纽约时报》上发表了一篇评论文章，题为《为什么芬兰的基本收入实验行不通》，并表示它有可能激励人们接受低薪和低生产力的工作。这是一个远非完美的实验，但它不应该是最终的结论。理想情况下，它是初稿。我们不能仅仅认为，你知道，
let's give this amount to some thousands of people and then we'll know for sure that's going to be other experiments before we can find out how to renew social security. Basically, if this experiment is at all successful or even if it's not, it should lead to another experiment and then another and then another. In Finland, isn't just as onion experiments with basic income, there will be experiments for what languages to teach in schools
让我们给几千人这笔钱，然后我们就会确定，在我们可以找出如何更新社会保障之前，还会有其他实验。基本上，如果这个实验有任何成功，或者即使它不成功，它也应该导致另一个实验，然后是另一个，再另一个。在芬兰，不仅仅是洋葱实验有基本收入，还会有关于学校教授什么语言的实验
how to change childcare, everything. According to their website, the experimentation office is working on 26 key projects nationally. And slowly, hopefully, Finland will use the design process to figure out if it's possible or worthwhile to try radically new ideas. Express, test, and cycle. Well, we ever get a basic income experiment right here in the U.S. It turns out we already had one decades ago. Avery explains after the break. So a lot of people here in the United States are talking about universal basic income and
如何改变儿童保育，一切皆有可能。根据他们的网站，实验办公室正在全国范围内开展26个关键项目。慢慢地，希望芬兰能利用设计过程来弄清楚尝试激进的新想法是否可能或值得。表达、测试和循环。好吧，我们会在美国这里进行基本收入实验吗？事实证明，几十年前我们就已经有了一个。艾弗里在休息后解释。所以美国很多人都在谈论全民基本收入，并且
arguing about why it's good and why it's bad, but to me it just seems like it's just not on the table at all. I just feel like there's something about the U.S. that makes it so it would never happen here. That basic income is basically something that could only be tested in Nordic welfare states. Yeah, it's the crazy thing about basic income is it's actually this very American idea and it was first proposed
争论它为什么好，为什么坏，但对我来说，它似乎根本就不可能实现。我只是觉得美国有什么东西让它永远不会在这里发生。基本收入基本上只能在北欧福利国家进行测试。是的，关于基本收入最疯狂的事情是它实际上是一个非常美国的想法，它最初是由美国开国元勋托马斯·潘恩提出
or at least kind of first mentioned by American founding father Thomas Payne. It's like, as American as Apple Pie, and in terms of basic income experiments, we've actually been down this road before as a nation here in the United States. We did some studies with basic income back in the 70s. I shall ask to change the framework of government itself. So we can make it again fully responsible for the needs and the wishes of the American
或者至少是第一次被提及。它就像苹果派一样美国，就基本收入实验而言，我们作为美国这个国家实际上以前走过这条路。我们在70年代做了一些关于基本收入的研究。我应该要求改变政府本身的框架。这样我们就可以让它再次完全负责美国人民的需求和愿望。
people. That's Richard Nixon. Richard Nixon wanted to see if you could guarantee a family of four $1,600 a year, which is equivalent to like $10,000 today, and he hints at it in this state of the Union address. Let us place a floor under the income of every family with children in America. Let us provide the means by which more can help themselves. Wow. And so yeah, and then he decided to really try and do it.
那是理查德·尼克松。理查德·尼克松想看看你是否能保证一个四口之家每年有1600美元，这相当于今天的10000美元左右，他在这次国情咨文中暗示了这一点。让我们为美国每个有孩子的家庭的收入设定一个底线。让我们提供更多人可以帮助自己的手段。哇。所以是的，然后他决定真正尝试去做。
Tens of millions of dollars were budgeted so that more than 8,500 Americans could be involved in experiments all around the country. And there were a bunch of different ones. And they were all had different people running them. And they tested like different variations of basic income and different ideas around it. And there was one in Seattle and one in Denver and one in Gary Indiana and one in North Carolina, just like, all kinds of places all over the country. And so why haven't I heard of these at all? I have no knowledge of this. And what did they find out?
数千万美元被列入预算，以便超过8500名美国人可以参与全国各地的实验。有很多不同的实验。它们都有不同的人在运行。他们测试了基本收入的不同变体和围绕它的不同想法。西雅图有一个，丹佛有一个，加里印第安纳有一个，北卡罗来纳有一个，就像全国各地各种各样的地方。那么为什么我根本没听说过这些呢？我对此一无所知。他们发现了什么？
Well, the results were kind of screwy because it wasn't like in a perfect scientific bubble, there were all these variations happening, all at the same time, and some of them were like different marginal tax rates and like different benefit levels and all those different kinds of stuff which makes it really difficult to just identify the effects
好吧，结果有点混乱，因为它不像在一个完美的科学泡沫中，所有这些变体都在同一时间发生，其中一些是不同的边际税率和不同的福利水平以及所有这些不同种类的东西，这使得很难确定效果
because you are testing so many different versions of it. And then actually the really big pitfall, like they did find some stuff, but the reason that it has been pretty much discarded to the sands of time was because people started analyzing the results before all the data was in. And so there were like these rumors swirling around that people were dropping out of the work force and just like enjoying this basic income. And it wasn't actually a statistically significant trend. It was just kind of a rumor, which can sometimes be more powerful than a fact. And there were also all these reports of increased separation and divorce rates. And that was considered really
因为你正在测试它的许多不同版本。然后实际上真正的大陷阱，就像他们确实发现了一些东西，但它被遗忘在时间沙滩上的原因是人们在所有数据出来之前就开始分析结果了。所以有传言说人们正在退出劳动力市场，只是享受这种基本收入。这实际上并不是一个具有统计学意义的趋势。这只是一种传言，有时比事实更有力量。还有所有关于分离和离婚率增加的报道。这被认为非常
scandalous and set off a lot of opposition. But then when the data was actually analyzed, it wasn't as large as it seems. There weren't that many more divorces. There were a few, but this wasn't necessarily a bad thing. Totally. Yeah. It just stopped the economic slavery of women. Exactly. Exactly. That's not so bad.
丑闻，并引发了许多反对。但当数据真正被分析时，它并没有看起来那么大。离婚并没有那么多。有一些，但这并不一定是坏事。完全正确。是的。它只是停止了女性的经济奴役。完全正确。完全正确。那也不错。
Yeah, but the American public didn't have the patience for nuance, and they were like, this will be the end of the family unit, so we can't tolerate it. And it's all just because they started chatting about it before they had- For the actual results. Yeah, before they had the numbers. It was kind of disregarded,
是的，但美国公众没有耐心去理解细微差别，他们觉得这将是家庭单位的终结，所以我们不能容忍它。这一切只是因为他们在拥有实际结果之前就开始谈论它。是的，在他们有数字之前。它被忽视了，
before we really had a chance to fully analyze the data. I think that's certainly a challenge that we're keeping in mind. This is Elizabeth Rhodes, and she is the research director of a basic income study that is happening at Y-combinator Research, which is a nonprofit research lab created by a startup accelerator called Y Combinator and she works like right down the street from
在我们真正有机会完全分析数据之前。我认为这当然是我们牢记的一个挑战。这是伊丽莎白·罗兹，她是Y-Combinator Research正在进行的一项基本收入研究的研究主任，这是一个由名为Y Combinator的创业加速器创建的非营利研究实验室，她在离我们办公室不远的街上工作
our office and she is helping to launch a basic income experiment nearby here in Oakland. We are in the process of we're doing a sort of a pre-pilot, a small group to sort of test some of the logistics and work through some of the questions around that and preparing for a larger randomized control trial that we hope to launch next year. After that local test, they want to really expand it. We're actually looking to do two US states in broader regions within two states. They have definitely learned from these early experiments to start small, expand slowly and to not promise too much
她正在帮助在奥克兰附近启动一项基本收入实验。我们正在进行一个预试点，一个小群体，以测试一些后勤工作并解决围绕它的一些问题，并为我们希望明年启动的更大规模的随机对照试验做准备。在当地测试之后，他们想真正扩大它。我们实际上正在寻求在美国两个州的更广泛地区进行。他们肯定从这些早期实验中吸取了教训，从小处着手，缓慢扩展，不要承诺太多
Because you know they want to wait for this experiment to fully play out Unlike Finland they are definitely doing this because of the robots and because they're based here in the Bay Area Which is like home of the gig economy and then just wanna see if this will make people happy in an era where robots take over all of our jobs. Right. Or jobs are not like jobs that are today. Like, they're gig jobs and therefore, having a basic income would ameliorate
因为你知道他们想等待这个实验完全发挥作用。与芬兰不同，他们绝对是因为机器人而这样做，因为他们总部位于湾区，这是零工经济的家园，他们只是想看看这是否会让人们在机器人接管我们所有工作的时代感到快乐。对。或者工作不像今天的工作。比如，它们是零工，因此，拥有基本收入将改善
a kind of economy that a lot of the Silicon Valley is helping to create. Exactly. But then on the other side of it, there a startup accelerator, they help businesses grow, and they're like, if this is what it takes, if they need a basic income in order to innovate, capital I, let's see if it'll work. I see. Yeah, and they just want to make sure that they don't set expectations too high. The study is going to run for several
硅谷正在帮助创造的一种经济。完全正确。但另一方面，他们是一个创业加速器，他们帮助企业成长，他们就像，如果这是所需要的，如果他们需要基本收入才能创新，大写的I，让我们看看它是否有效。我明白了。是的，他们只是想确保他们不会把期望定得太高。这项研究将持续几年，
years, and so I don't expect to see changes overnight in any way. And so I think we really need to give it time. So in doing this research about basic income, I've come across a thousand polarizing think pieces that are either like, you be eyes a great idea and we should do this right now. Or like, this is a terrible idea and we need to stop it. But realistically, it's going to be years before we know what we can learn from this privatized American experiment, or from the finished experiment for that matter. Because most of the arguments we're having about basic income at this point in time,
所以我并不指望一夜之间看到任何变化。所以我认为我们真的需要给它时间。所以在做关于基本收入的这项研究时，我遇到了成千上万篇两极分化的文章，要么是，UBI是一个好主意，我们现在就应该这样做。或者，这是一个糟糕的主意，我们需要停止它。但现实情况是，在我们要知道我们可以从这个私有化的美国实验，或者芬兰实验中学到什么之前，还需要几年时间。因为我们目前关于基本收入的大多数争论，
in all of basic incomes, many different definitions and variations, it's all based in speculation. We're having a debate without data. And no one has solid answers yet about what basic income would mean for the national tax code or inflation or unemployment rates or the economy or the robots or our happiness and well-being. And right now all we know is that different experimenters
在所有基本收入的许多不同定义和变体中，这一切都基于猜测。我们正在进行一场没有数据的辩论。没有人有确切的答案，关于基本收入对国家税法、通货膨胀、失业率、经济、机器人或我们的幸福和福祉意味着什么。目前我们所知道的是，世界各地的不同实验者
all around the world are trying to figure out some answers. We just don't know them yet. So this is gonna end like all radio stories and which is Time will tell. Only Time will tell. But for now Time will tell. Well thanks Avery. Thanks woman. 99% of visible was produced this week by Avery Trouffleman, mixed and tech production by Shereefusif, music by Sean Rial. Our senior producer is Katie Mingle. Kurt Colstead is the digital director.
都在试图找出一些答案。我们只是还不知道它们。所以这将像所有广播故事一样结束，那就是时间会证明一切。只有时间会证明一切。但目前时间会证明一切。好吧，谢谢艾弗里。谢谢罗曼。本周的《99%隐形》由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼制作，谢里夫·尤西夫进行混音和技术制作，肖恩·里亚尔配乐。我们的高级制作人是凯蒂·明格尔。库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。
The rest of the staff is Delaney Hall, Emmett Fitzgerald, Taren Mazza, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to our fixer, Ali Sulu Puisto, and Yana Svonin, who recorded Sana for free. Thanks also to Tim Wong,
其余的工作人员是德莱尼·霍尔、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、塔伦·马扎，以及我罗曼·马斯。本周特别感谢我们的联络人阿里·苏鲁·普伊斯托和免费录制萨娜的亚娜·斯沃宁。也感谢蒂姆·黄，
Kara Rose de Fambio, Asmo Suloranta, Yuha Le Penin, and Vili Vecco Polca. We are a project of Dunne 1.7K, I'll W in San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row, in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. 99% of visible is part of radio topia from PRX, a collective of the best most innovative shows in all of podcasting. We are supported by the Night Foundation and Coin Carrying listeners, just like you.
卡拉·罗斯·德·法比奥、阿斯莫·苏洛兰塔、尤哈·勒·佩宁和维利·维科·波尔卡。我们是旧金山Dunne 1.7K, I'll W的一个项目，在美丽的奥克兰市中心制作。《99%隐形》是PRX RadioTopia的一部分，这是一个汇集了播客界最优秀、最具创新性节目的集体。我们得到了奈特基金会和像你一样的硬币携带听众的支持。
You can find 99% invisible and join discussion about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI Orc, where on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. If you ever wondered what it takes to get a business like a gas station or a fast food place on one of those blue highway signs, it turns out there are rules. And you can read about them on our website, 99pi.org. Radio to PO. From PRX.
你可以在Facebook上找到《99%隐形》并加入关于该节目的讨论。你可以在推特上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PI_org，我们在Instagram、Tumblr和Reddit上也有账号。如果你曾经想知道在那些蓝色高速公路标志上放置像加油站或快餐店这样的企业需要什么，事实证明是有规则的。你可以在我们的网站99pi.org上阅读它们。RadioTopia。来自PRX。
you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你 这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。